there we go
all right ernie ernie uh
where'd you go where are you from
originally where'd you grow up
uh cuban new mexico
white house lake in new mexico
yeah and uh tell me about your family
you're navajo
my mom's not a host but my dad
and son ain't nothing cheyenne
nothing
[Music]
but they lost each other
how was your childhood i didn't know
what was going on
but mom's gone yeah
i came into town
so you drink i'm still
here when did you start drinking alcohol
oh my first time
i was 13 years old
mama had her bar in the home
i didn't know that was in denver
hey my dad they had their body over
then one day
i had a friend it was a white boy
on the side on the street
and because you know what
he left he my mom left
for the weekend
and i didn't drink nothing
then the little boy came back
you know what let's just try that
whiskey
and we did that's why i started drinking
whiskey
at 13. what is your drink
what did you drink today
actually just say yes vodka
have you drunk some of the other things
that people will use to get drunk like
uh
like hairspray and gatorade or lysol or
what else what other stuff is it what
are the things of you i stole it
you stole what hairspray
lifestyle i did all that stuff
you drink it it gets you it gets you
drunk
huh
what about like things like perfume or
rubbing alcohol i
did it i did it
what's the difference between vodka and
uh and rubbing alcohol
or perfume or lice that's the same thing
same thing it just gets you hot you get
drunk
yeah and you sleep on the street it gets
cold at night no
yeah i've been on the street
in the winter it gets very cold here in
new mexico
yeah people die sometimes from that
right
i don't know but
i did all that
and i'm trying to go home
what do you do for money how do you how
do you get money
just every day because
just drinking
you beg for money and people give it to
you i make money
how do you make money panhandle
yeah i made money and then
some days is good not today it's not
do you have children i have nobody
no family no friends no i don't have
one's
my sister
your sister's all you have left
i'm my brother too
i just drink
my brother quenching over there the
motto
i'm supposed to get out today or
tomorrow
did you once live on a reservation huh
did you once live on an indian
reservation
not a hazard mine is
it's different
we pay for our lands
i'm not on the regulations
i pay for my land
where i live
these guys arizona did nothing
they don't make nothing for it
but i pray for me
and then now
we got oil whatever
oil cold water
that's how we get our paint with them
and then i go out my dad's from
montana
[Music]
the cheyenne part of your family we're
fighting
aims i don't know if you guys know
we don't we're not here we only
treat ourselves [ __ ]
i don't know me
fight
my uncles and
[Music]
they said that weird
but they claim
anime cost with my
ex they
killed her up there
they fell in the bed
and to wash some wash
she died in the on the street yeah
they killed her but he killed him
because
she would she spoke out for us
they found their body over their snow
and then my brothers joined their
peltier dennis banks
yep i'm not scared
they can kill me i'm giving [ __ ]
for the government
they know me they know my family
were amen
like they can kill me i don't care
they did to my grandma too
my grandma
um
for many reasons it's hard to be native
american isn't it today
no we have our rights
we're not scared i'm not scared of them
they can [ __ ] kill me right now
i'm breathing
i'm not getting
[Music]
but they're gone
and i'm done here
come on my mom's hand is from
the site
okay ernie well thank you for talking
with me
wow that's right there
thank you
you